potential ghost writing quote unquote
clients are everywhere they exist
everywhere anyone with a big YouTube
channel probably needs a Ghost Rider
anyone with a big podcast probably needs
a Ghostwriter anyone with the company
probably needs a Ghostwriter you know
and it's becoming less and less
stigmatized like the same way that you
go I want to make videos I'm going to
hire a video editor well the writing's
the same way you're like I want to write
tweets LinkedIn posts articles
newsletters whatever you're like I need
a writer you know so that stigma doesn't
really exist anymore or less and less
the what it actually looks like is you
just get on the phone with the person or
get on Zoom or whatever and you just go
okay
let's forget the Whole 30 000 foot
strategy like this one thing what do you
want to say
like just one it's a tweet it's a thread
it's an article I always tried to remind
people like we're not gonna figure out
your entire life mission here right that
will reveal itself yep you know a mentor
I had a great quote which is
um you can't steer a stationary ship
right if you're just sitting at your
desk and you're just looking out into
the world you can anticipate it all you
want but the moment that ship leaves the
harbor if it starts raining your plan is
out the window right so I would say that
to these people over and over again and
be like the the end will reveal itself
for now let's just focus on what is the
one thing you want to write and all
you're doing is just hurting their
thinking you know you're just kind of
whittling it down
um getting clear on what it is that they
want to say in this one piece and the
process that I did is I would take the
phone call I would record it and I would
use this website called rev which allows
you to transcribe things I would get the
transcript and I liked to think of
ghostwriting myself as I'm not writing
I'm
I'm deleting so you have a you have a
transcript and they're giving you all
the information and your job isn't
really to sit down and recreate it your
job is to remove all the tangents and
all the fluff and all the things that
don't have to do with the one thing that
they're trying to say and then you're
just using their words and reorganizing
it that's the way I liked thinking of
ghost writing and
it's a skill but if you can get good at
it I mean you can make a killing
yeah like it's only it's only recently
this that there's been so like I work
with a Ghostwriter for like LinkedIn
posts and stuff because it's like
I want to convert my videos or I've
already said this stuff into tweet
threads and Linkedin posts but I sure as
hell don't want to do that myself so
like cape who wants to who wants to help
out with this and now that I've kind of
seen what that process of working with a
Ghostwriter is like I'm just kind of
thinking like
one of the
one of the ultimate side hustles
these days is to be is to be a video
editor because now having tried hiring
video editors it's just an absolute
Nightmare and most people are well suck
at it and if someone just took my
skillshare class over a weekend they
could become like really good at video
editing and just like why do why don't
more people do this if any time people
email me and be like hey I'm a student
and I want to make money on the side was
like video editing is like a good
starting point teach yourself the skill
find find YouTubers who need editing
because they all do especially like
podcasts everything except like content
stuff but increasingly I'm starting to
say it to people it's like hey you've
got two options video editing or writing
like actually if you can if you are good
at writing like if you're a student and
you've written essays and you can
appreciate what like blog post writing
is compared to essay writing there's
like zillions of like the local
orthodontists the local lawyer the local
accountant they all need ghostwriters
way more so than video editors actually
and it's just it seems like an
incredible opportunity it's yeah it is
incredible and to be honest it's even
I even think it's even easier now than
even five six seven years ago when I was
getting into it which is
just think about how many creators there
are
and how the whole game if you are a
profitable Creator if you have some sort
of business or product or service
connected to the to your creation
attention engine right
you need to scale yourself on the
internet with words
fifty percent of it could either be
video audio and the other fifty percent
is actual words and language and so the
lowest barrier to entry is a writer
going to Someone Like You and going I'm
going to take your entire Archive of
YouTube videos you've already done the
work and I'm going to extract all of the
written content that you haven't created
yet right and so as a Ghostwriter it's
almost like humbling yourself and
realizing you aren't getting paid to sit
down and like be brilliant and quote
unquote ghost write or ghost think right
you already did the thinking The Ghost
Writer just needs to go through your
library and go I'm going to scale you
with words and you can make six figures
doing that from your you know bedroom in
your sweatpants I mean that is not a
hard job to get and the way I like to
frame it to people is
the easiest and fastest way to do it is
to do it for free first
go find a Creator go find an
entrepreneur go find someone that you
think should be scaling themselves with
words on the internet and go I'll do
your first week of content for free I'll
write 10 threads for you for free I'll
write five blog posts for you for free
if you can do it well that person will
throw money at you hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye